Go ahead, sister. Let's go.
>> Okay. Um, it's it's about the Jewish
people. So,
>> I'm a big- time pro supporter of Israel.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's it's that's
it's ironic you would mention that
because I'm going to talk about is it's
time God's timing is beautiful.
>> So, you are pro-Zionist.
>> Oh, like I mean the whole Bible you
can't be Christian be anti- So,
>> no, it's not about being anti-Jewish.
You can't be Jesus's Jew. The greatest
creature that God created was a Jewish
woman named the blessed mother. That's
not what we're talking about. There's a
difference between not being anti-Jewish
and being pro-Zionist. You said you're
pro-Israel. That means you're
pro-Zionist. Why?
>> Um well, because in the Bible it's it's
mapped that is their land and that
that's where the
>> Who told you that?
>> Will take place.
>> Yeah. But who told you that? because
you're going to a certain church that
teaches you what's called
dispensationalism, a dispensational view
>> of the scriptures. That's not
necessarily what the New Testament
teaches. Nor is it the view of the
church historically. That's more of a
modern teaching.
>> I know that this is what you've been
taught because I was taught that. So
that's number one. So number two, were
you taught they're still God's chosen
people?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, bad theology. Can you stop going
to the church that you're going to?
>> I really like it.
>> Yeah, but they're teaching you bad
theology.
>> Uh, New Testament says the nation of
Israel is no longer God's people. The
people of God is the church. So, you got
to change your theologies. This is see
now I again, sister, I want to just bear
witness to the Lord God. I was about to
discuss this. You being here today,
>> you being married to a Muslim, you are
confirmation to me. And I pray I don't
speak presumptuously. May the Holy
Spirit save me from Aaron. And I'm in
line with the spirit that you are
actually
for me confirmation that the spirit
wants me to address this because of bad
theology because I was going to talk
about Palestinians and Israelis and try
to be as honest as I can and I'm going
to offend people.
>> So number one, your view about Israel is
wrong. This is why you're fighting.
You're fighting a a battle that's not
worth fighting because you have a wrong
view of Israel. They're not God's chosen
people. Have you read your New
Testament?
>> Yes.
>> Are you sure?
Go to Matthew 21. Open up your Bible.
Matthew 21, read 33 to 44.
All right. Read this. Jesus is going to
give a parable. Matthew 21 33- 44. Start
reading 33.
>> Okay. Listen to another parable. There
was a landowner who planted a vineyard.
He put a wall around it, dug a wine
press in it, and built a watchtower. He
vineyard farmers and moved to another
place. When the harvest time approached,
he sent his servants to the tenants to
collect his fruit. The tenant seized his
servants. They beat one, killed another,
and stoned a third. Then he sent other
servants to them, more than the first
time. and the tenants treated them the
same way. Last of all, he sent his son
to them. They will respect my son, he
said. But when the tenants saw the son,
they said to each other, "This is the
heir. Come, let's kill him and take his
inheritance." So they took him and threw
him out of the vineyard and killed him.
>> Now before you move on, you understand
what the parable is about, right?
>> Yes.
>> The vineyard is what? Israel
>> and the tenants, the vine dressers are
the rulers, right?
>> Mhm. Yes.
>> And their last chance, their last hope
of getting it right was what? What did
the owner who's God the Father do as
their last chance to get right? He sent
his son last. Right.
>> Right.
>> All right. So then Jesus already says
their what response will be? They'll
kill him.
>> Yes.
>> When they kill him, what is God going to
do? Now read. Now read. Continue reading
in 44.
>> Okay. Therefore, when the owner of the
vineyard comes, what will he do to those
tenants? Um Jesus said to them, "Have
you never read in the scripture? The
stone the builders rejected has become
the cornerstone. The Lord has done this,
and it is marvelous in our eyes.
Therefore, I tell you that the kingdom
of God will be taken away from you.
>> From who?
>> Given to a people who will produce.
>> The king of God will be taken away from
who?
>> From the Israelites.
>> Yeah. So, why would you say they're
God's chosen people? Jesus just said,
"When you kill me and reject me, the
kingdom will be taken away from you."
So, where did you get there? God's
chosen people.
I think I got it from
>> the misreading of the Old Testament.
Yeah, I know. Now, so you saw what he
said. The kingdom will be taken away
from you, right?
>> Yes.
>> All right. So, that's number one. Now,
number two, let me tell you who the true
Israelites are. I'm just going to give
you scripture. I'm going to give you the
Bible. It gets people get upset. They
get upset. That's between them and God.
I I answer to the Lord, not to people
who will try to demonize me and say I'm
anti-Semitic. Number one, I can't be
anti-Semitic. I'm a Semite.
>> I'm a son of Shem. I'm Assyrian. I am a
descendant of Shem from his son Asher.
That's in Genesis. You can read it.
Number two, I believe my God became a
Jew, which Muslims hate that I say that
Jesus is a Jew, a son of David, and he's
God Almighty in the flesh. And number
three, I love and honor a Jewish woman
as the greatest creature of God, the
blessed mother, the holy mother, the
mother of my Lord, my God, Mary. She's
Jewish and I love her as the greatest of
all creatures. And I love her more than
my mother and I love her more than my
daughters. So there's no way in hell
someone can accuse me of being
anti-Jewish. That's a lie because that's
that's only slandering because they
can't refute me. So keep that in mind.
So now let me show you who a true Jew
is. According to the Jews that wrote the
New Testament, these are Jews.
>> These Jews are going to tell you who the
true Jews are. They're going to tell
you, not me. Okay? So Jesus just said,
"The kingdom taken away from you.
Kingdom is not yours anymore." Look what
the Lord also says. Go to Matthew 8,
read 10-13. Matthew 8:10-13.
Matthew 8:10-13.
When Jesus heard this, he was amazed and
said to those following him, "Truly I
tell you, I have not found anyone in
Israel with such great faith. I say to
you that many will come from the east
and the west and will take their places
at the feast with Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob in the kingdom of heaven.
But the subjects of the kingdom will go
thrown out
>> into the darkness where there will be
weeping and nashing of teeth." So wait,
the subjects of the kingdom at that time
were the Jews, right?
>> Yes.
>> But Jesus said the subjects of the
kingdom will be thrown in hell. Whereas
people from the east and the west,
meaning non-Jews,
those are not ethnically Jewish. They
will eat with Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob.
But you won't.
>> And why did he say that? Because a
centurion, a Roman soldier, commander of
a 100 soldiers,
a Roman soldier, a commander of 100
soldiers, showed such faith in Jesus
that he says, "I have yet to see such
faith in all of Israel." Do you hear
what our Lord said? This gentile who's a
commander of 100 Roman soldiers trained
to kill. He says he has more faith than
anyone in Israel. And that's people from
the east and the west will sit with
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. But you Jews
who are given the kingdom, you'll be
thrown in hell for rejecting Jesus. You
see that?
>> Okay.
>> All right. Let it trouble you because
you need to unlearn what you've been
taught. Now, go to Romans 2 26 to 29.
I'm going to show you scripture. So,
this you got to change your mindset.
This pro- Zionism, that's not biblical.
You're distorting scripture to be a
pro-Zionist.
They deceived you. You're not pro-
Zionist. You're not pro Palestine.
You're pro-Lord Jesus Christ and pro-
kingdom of Christ. And Christ's kingdom
doesn't favor any human government.
Christ's kingdom will conquer all human
governments, including Zionism.
Zionism is an abomination to God.
Zionism is not based on the lordship of
Jesus Christ. Zionism is antithetical,
anti-gosspel, anti-Christian just as
much as a Muslim government. Now go to
Romans 2:26-29.
>> Okay.
So then if those who are not circumcised
keep the laws requirements, will they
not be regarded as though they were
circumcised?
>> You understand his point there before
you because you got to understand what
you read. What is he talking about? What
is Paul saying here?
>> Okay. So the the ones that are not
circumcised are the Gentiles or the ones
Jewish. Okay? And he's saying to the
Jews, you who boast being Jewish and you
have the law. When you have a Gentile
who keeps God's moral commands and
ethics, but he's not circumcised, won't
God consider him as if he had been
circumcised?
>> Yes.
>> Now watch what he says to those Jews who
are circumcised but break the law. Now
read it.
The one who is not circumcised
physically and yet obeys the law will
condemn you who even though you have the
written code and circumcision are a lawb
breaker.
>> So who's better in the eyes of God?
Ethnically Jew who breaks God's law or a
Gentile who's not circumcised but honors
God and keeps his ethical moral demands.
>> Well, a Gentile who honors God because
the I I understand the circumcision.
>> Well, now it gets better though
>> because now you're going to see who the
true Jew is. 2829.
>> A person is not a Jew who is one only
outwardly, nor a circumcision merely
outward and physical. No, a person is a
Jew who is one inwardly. And
circumcision is circumcision of the
heart by the spirit, not by the written
code.
>> So you just you you were just told what
a true Jew is. A true Jew is what?
um someone who
follows the Lord's laws and ethics in
their heart and truly and not just by
outward.
>> In other words, yeah, you're a follower
of Jesus Christ because for Paul to
follow the law is to obey Jesus Christ.
So, you're just told right now, a true
Jew is one who's spiritual, circumcised
spiritually, born of the spirit, united
to Christ. And now, I'm going to show
you this is the teaching of the entire
New Testament. And I'm going to show you
what the New Testament says about those
Jews who reject Jesus. They're said to
be fake Jews. They're not really Jews.
In fact, would you be shocked if I
showed you Paul saying, "The Jews who
reject Jesus, they're actually
Ishelites. They're the sons of Hagar,
the descendants of Ishmael. They're not
the descendants of Sarah." Would you be
shocked if I showed you that?
>> Yes.
>> You would be shocked, right?
>> That's a huge thing.
>> I'm going to show it to you. I'm going
to show it to you from Paul. But I want
everyone to hear. She's going to be
shocked when I show her. Paul's saying
the Jews who don't follow Jesus but
follow the law of Moses, they are
actually the descendants of Hagar, the
descendants of Ishmael, they're not the
descendants of Sarah. Galatians 4:es
21 to31. It's right there. Galatians 4
21- 31. It's right there.
>> Tell me who you want to be under the
law. Are you not aware of what the law
says? For it is written that Abraham had
two sons, one by the slave and the by
the free woman.
>> His son by the slave woman was born
according to
>> Get closer to the mic so we can hear
you.
>> His son by the slave woman was born
according to the flesh. But his son by
the free woman was born as the result of
a divine promise.
>> These things are being taken figure.
The woman represented represent two
covenants. One covenant is from Mount Si
and bears children who are to be slaves.
This is Hagar. Now Hagar stands for
Mount Si in Arabia and corresponds to
the present city of Jerusalem.
>> Now did you catch it?
Jerusalem on earth is Hagar.
>> Okay.
>> Did you hear it?
>> Yeah. Hagar stands for Mount Si and
corresponds to the present city of
Jerusalem. Okay.
>> So, here you are a pro-Zionist, pro-
Israel. You are fighting for the Jews
who are living in the land that Paul
said is the land of bondage. The land
that enslaves
the descendants of Hagar, not of Sarah.
>> Okay.
>> I didn't say that. Paul just said that,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, then what is true Jerusalem?
And who are the true sons and daughters
of Sarah? Now keep reading.
>> Okay. Um, but the Jerusalem that is
above is free, and she is our mother.
For it is written,
>> "Be glad, barren woman, you who never
bore a child. Shout for joy and cry
aloud, you who were never in labor,
because
>> oh, because more are the children of the
desolate woman than of her who has a
husband." Now you brothers and sisters
like Isaac are children of promise.
>> Who are the children of promise who
belong to Isaac?
>> Who's he talking to?
>> Christians.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> But the Jews who reject Jesus, they are
sons of Hagar. Keep reading.
>> Okay. At that time, the son born
according to the flesh persecuted the
son born by the power of the spirit. It
is the same now.
>> It is the same now. Notice just like
Ishmael who was born of the flesh, not
of God's promise because God didn't
promise that he would give Abraham a son
from Hagar.
That so Ishmael was simply their human
decision to do so. But God did promise
to give Abraham a son from Sarah. And
just like in Genesis 21, Sarah told
Abraham, "Get rid of the woman, the bond
woman, the bond woman and her son. M
>> because he has no share with Isaac. And
God said, "Listen to what Sarah said."
And so here Paul is saying just like in
Genesis 21, God
had Hagar and her son
banished from Isaac so that she was
removed. Paul is saying, "You too, you
Christians, you are like Isaac. Get rid
of the bond women and her son." And who
are they? the Judaizers, those Jews who
are telling Christians who are not
ethnically Jewish, you have to keep the
law of Moses and get circumcised. And he
says they are Ishelites. Have nothing to
do with them. Get rid of them.
>> Okay, finish it though. All the way to
31.
>> Get rid of the slave woman and her son.
For the slave woman's son will never
share in the inheritance with the free
woman's son. Therefore, brothers and
sisters, we are not children of the
slave woman, but of the free woman.
>> Wow. So, I want to ask you a question.
I'm a little baffled here.
>> Who are the sons of the slave woman
according to what Paul just said?
>> Um, those that are not going to those
that are not, I guess, children of God
or will share in the inheritance are not
Christian.
>> Who are they in that context? Who are
they?
um
>> the Jews.
>> Hey, okay,
>> he's talking about the Jews. That's why
he mentioned Mount Sai in Arabia, which
corresponds to Jerusalem. Those Jews who
still want to keep the Mosaic law, who
still want to follow Moses, they are the
sons of the bond woman, have nothing to
do with them.
And what did he say about Jerusalem? Is
Jerusalem,
is that the true Jerusalem? And is that
the Jerusalem that God delights in? Or
is that the Jerusalem
that is represented and typified in
Hagar, the bond woman, not the free?
>> No, I think what you said, the one
that's typified.
>> Don't think what I said, he said it
there. Galatians 4:21-25. Right. I
didn't say. So, make sure you're
understanding what you're reading,
>> right?
So Jerusalem on earth is that
the true Jerusalem that lights God's
heart or is that the Jerusalem that is
typified in Hagar? Hagar the bond woman
who gives birth to children in slavery
who are not free.
What is that Jerusalem on earth?
Any tear from you? Because if you're
silent I can't read your heart here. Let
me try to reach your heart.
What is the Jerusalem on earth?
>> The Jerusalem on earth is just a mapped
out piece of land, I guess, over in next
to Egypt.
>> And who points to that Jerusalem, Sarah,
or
>> is it saying that Hagar points to that
Jerusalem?
>> Then you didn't read it with
understanding. See, that's why I got to
ask you questions. If you don't
understand, you're not going to get the
point. Reread Galatians 4 21-26 until
you get it.
>> Okay?
>> Read it. You're not going to go anywhere
until you get it. If you don't get it,
then you're not going to see it because
the indoctrination of the church he went
to is very heavy. And by the power of
the Holy Spirit, may he set you free
from that indoctrination. Read Galatians
4:21-26. Reread it.
>> For it is written that Abraham had two
sons, one by the slave woman and by free
woman. His son by the slave woman was
born according to the flesh.
But his son by the free woman was born
as a result of a divine promise. So I'm
just stopping so I understand
everyone
>> promised. Yeah. Who was promised?
>> Isaac was
>> was Ishmael promised?
>> No.
>> Exactly. So now pay attention which
Jerusalem
corresponds to Ishmael and Hagar and
which one corresponds to Sarah and
Isaac. Pay attention now.
>> These things are being taken
figuratively. The woman represents two
covenants.
>> Wait, the woman meaning Sarah and Hagar
represent two covenants. a covenant made
on Mount Si which corresponds to
Jerusalem on earth and the other
covenant that is heavenly. Keep reading.
>> Okay. One covenant is from Mount Si and
bears children who are to be slaves.
This is Hagar. So this is the one of the
flesh. Now Hagar stands for Mount Si in
Arabia and corresponds to the present
city of Jerusalem.
>> Can it be any clearer? You just read it
the second time. Okay.
>> So the Jerusalem on earth is who
figuratively
>> is is figuratively Hagar which is the
the children that are were born of the
flesh which was Ishmael.
>> And so which children is Paul saying are
Ishelites? Who's he talking about?
Because he said two covenants. The
covenant of Mount Sai that was made with
who?
>> The Israelites.
>> You know you just admit Israelites are
the sons of Hagar.
That's what you just said if you
understood what you just said because if
the covenant of Mount Sai which is in
Arabia which corresponds to Jerusalem
that is symbolized in Hagar that means
all who belong to that covenant are the
sons and daughters of Hagar
but that covenant was made with the
Israelites.
>> This is a lot to take. You better
believe it. But you asked. I can't lie
to you. I can't tickle your ears. If you
believe your New Testament,
Paul, who's a Jew, so he's not
anti-Semitic, just told you the covenant
made on Sai, which is Jerusalem on
earth. that is now
typified, represented, symbolized in
Hagar
because Hagar is the bond woman who gave
birth to a son who was in bondage.
And these Jews, if they're trying to now
merit righteousness before God by
keeping the Mosaic law, they will be in
bondage to sin and they will come under
God's wrath. So, understand the point.
Earthly Jerusalem after rejecting Jesus
is no longer the Jerusalem of God. Then
what is the Jerusalem of God? Well, read
continue.
>> Okay.
>> What is the Jerusalem that delights God,
that pleases God, which Sarah
represents?
>> Okay,
>> keep reading.
>> But the Jerusalem that above is free and
she is our mother for
>> what's your mother? the the free
Jerusalem.
>> And where's that at?
>> I don't think it's an actual place.
>> No, it is. It's heavenly Jerusalem.
>> Okay,
>> that's where you got to know your Bible.
It's Hebrews 12:22- 24. And Revelation
21 says, "And I saw Jerusalem coming
down out of heaven like a bride adorned
for her husband."
>> Okay,
>> that's why I got your Bible. So, which
Jerusalem is the Jerusalem that delights
the heart of God? the heavenly Jerusalem
in Hebrews and Revelation
>> and go to Hebrews 12:22- 24 to show you
that the real Jerusalem is the one in
heaven and it's coming down at the end
of the age when the Lord returns.
Hebrews 12 uh 222 to 24. So you don't
think I'm making it up. Hebrews 12:22 to
24.
>> Okay.
But you have come to Mount Zion to the
city of the living God, the heavenly
Jerusalem.
>> The what? the heavenly Jerusalem. So
>> there's a Zion in heaven,
>> I guess. So
>> don't guess. Come on, sister. Don't
guess.
>> According to this, yes.
>> So there's a Zion in heaven.
>> Yes.
>> And that's a city of the living God.
>> Heavenly Jerusalem.
>> Yes. You have come to thousands upon
thousands of angels in joyful assembly,
to the church of the firstborn, whose
names are written in heaven.
>> You have come to God, the judge of all,
to the spirits of the righteous made
perfect,
>> to Jesus, the mediator of a new
covenant, and to the sprinkled blood
that speaks a better word than the blood
of Abel.
>> So in heavenly Jerusalem, that's the
city of God.
Yes.
>> And in that city of God, you have Zion
and Jerusalem.
>> Yes.
>> And who lives there? God the Father. Who
lives there? Jesus Christ. Who lives
there? Myriads of angels. Who lives
there? The spirits of those who died in
Christ who are now perfected because
their bodies are in the dust. Their
spirits are there. And what are they
having there? They're having church.
Because there's church there, right?
>> Right.
>> So which is the true Jerusalem that God
delights in?
>> The heavenly Jerusalem.
>> Exactly. Because you remember what Jesus
said when the Jews rejected him, the
kingdom would take be taken away from
them and the city and the temple were
destroyed as a sign that God was done
with them. Go to Galatians chapter 3.
>> Okay.
>> Now, I want you to see who the true
offspring of Abraham is. Are you ready?
>> Yes.
Read Galatians 3:15-18.
Galatians 3:15-18.
>> Brothers and sisters, let me take an
example from everyday life. Just as no
one can set aside or add to a human
covenant that has been duly established.
So it is in this case. The promises were
spoken to Abraham and to his seed.
Scripture say and to seeds meaning many
people but
>> scripture does not say it says scripture
does not say and to seeds many people
but to seed.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Because you must the way you read
it I heard you saying scripture says and
to seeds.
>> Okay. Oh does not say and to seeds.
>> Yeah. Now read it. meaning many people
but and to your seed meaning one person
who is Christ.
>> So who's the true seed of Abraham?
>> Christ.
>> He is the seed, right?
>> Yes.
>> The one person Christ. He is the seed,
right?
>> Yes. The one seed. Yes.
>> All right. Now go to Galatians 3:26-29.
Now watch this. Galatians 3:26-29.
So in Christ Jesus, you are all children
of God through faith. For all of you who
were baptized into Christ have clothed
yourselves with Christ. There is neither
Jew nor Gentile, neither slave nor free.
>> Wait, there's no longer Jew nor Gentile?
>> Yes.
>> So why are you making a big deal over
Israel against Palestine?
Um,
>> reread that again.
>> There is neither Jew nor Gentile,
neither slave nor free, nor is there
male and female. For you are all in one
Christ Jesus.
>> For you are all one in Christ Jesus.
>> All one in Christ Jesus.
>> And then what are you? If you're in
Christ, what are you? 29.
If you belong to Christ, then you are
Abraham's seed and hes according to the
promise.
>> Wait, sister, the seed of Abraham are
believers in Jesus who are baptized into
Jesus.
>> Yes.
>> So a Gentile who believes in Jesus and
is baptized in Jesus, he is the son. She
is the daughter of Abraham, the seed of
Abraham.
>> Yes. So why are you making a big deal
over the state of Israel and taking
their side over against Palestine? You
don't take anyone's side.
You just read from a Jew. Those who are
baptized in Christ,
ethnically Jewish or a Gentile or a male
or a female, you're all one. And you are
the seed of Abraham. Abraham is all of
your father. He's the father of all of
you.
So now a Jew who rejects Jesus,
Netanyahu, and a Palestinian who loves
Jesus and he's baptized in Jesus. In the
eyes of Jesus, which of those two is the
real Jew?
>> The Palestinian is
>> you just destroyed
your case for being pro-Israel.
>> This is a lot. You have to understand.
And
>> I know it's a lot because you've been
indoctrinated like I was. But what I'm
trying to get at is if you believe your
Bible and you let Jesus tell you what to
believe and the Holy Spiritfilled
apostles and the New Testament writers,
Paul wrote that he's a Jew. I didn't
write it. I didn't write Galatians 3.
And in Galatians 3, he told you there's
neither Jew nor Gentile, Greek, neither
male nor female, neither free nor slave.
You are all one if you've been baptized
in Christ. And all of you are the seed
of Abraham.